à
pour vivre dans nos plaines il faut
apprendre à se débrouiller par soi même
des vêtements de ville ne sont pas du
tout adaptés à la vie dans nos plaines
à partir d'aujourd'hui ta vie est ici tu
dois oublier le monde d'où tu viens
tu viens me sauver la vie je n'ai pas
blessé
savage sais rien ces chiens là haut tu
le connais en tout cas il est pas d'ici
et celle du tibet sont les seuls maîtres
sur la voir
il se sent peut-être proche de lui parce
qu'il vient d'ailleurs
d'abord
[Musique]
oh
beaucoup tu as été super tu as
apprivoisé un grand ancien du tibet
alors quand ils obligent leurs maîtres
ce matin je suis tombé sur un homme qui
avait été tué et blessures n'avaient
rien à voir avec celle infligée par des
loupes si ce n'était pas des lots alors
qu'était ce c'était l'oeuvre d'un démon
je sais pas où il est passé il construit
pour tuer avec une cruauté paille tu
crois qu'il n'est retourné d'où il
venait
je n'en suis pas sûr mais c'est possible
appâté sociale
qui ne ferait jamais une chose pareille
il est prouvé que yogi a tué un homme de
la batterie aussitôt perdre est
incapable d'aimer kits de soin tout a
commencé lorsque cette bête est arrivé
dans la plaine voulez-vous être sa
prochaine victime
[Musique]